[Music]
[Music]
so
yes
hello everybody uh if you can hear me i
want you to to go to your chat and say
hello
if you can em i want you to go to your
chat right now and say hello
oh great
okay i can just see a few people writing
on the chat
all right all right
is
okay uh we welcome you everybody
i want you to write the number one
let's do that
um
mr victor abel please help me uh
people whose
war are not muted
um real quick
uh we will get started
in the next uh
next
five minutes
so um just want you to just stay tuned
let's leave uh leave space for others to
join
so
um
oh great
great some other questions
hello mister your favorite we cannot
hear you we can't hear you i think you
are mute
so i have to restart
all right how about now can you hear me
yes so please you can start and start
from beginning
okay hello everybody uh we welcome you
to this information session today on ole
miss logic research fellowship today our
focus is to discuss the following to
help
give provide guide
to brief info about pine biotech yeah we
also
uh love to introduce you to the research
fellowship program to share uh with you
about the program format the resources
available to all participants during the
programs
that include the highly rated
asynchronous basis and specialized
courses we also are going to share with
you how to register for the training
programs and the special offers
available for the homies logic africa
community
members
on this note i would love to introduce
you to who's speaking so my name is
russia
i'm a molecular
biology and uh genetics expert
i am going to be i'm also a faculty of
uh of eureka or mislogic africa
um
team i'm the community engagement
manager and i'm gonna also be one of the
technical support and mentor that you're
gonna be having yeah so straight to what
you can see on your screen uh pine
biotech is a bioinformatic company
that is working towards providing
cutting edge bioinformatics research and
education along with several other
university partners
prime biotech's mission is to simply
find you know to simplify bioinformatics
and uh
advanced research through cutting ahead
user friendly and a high-guided next
generation sequency
sequencing
data analysis platform ultimately
our work is for
a future where we collaborate and call
and contribute
enhance human health and
well-being together by in on by enabling
biological research and
discovery wheat
relevant solutions
and support
i would love that you get to meet
persons on this team
uh as you might be aware the omex logic
program has been possible due to the
effort of extraordinary
team including the ceo and the
co-founder
eli broski and other co-founders of the
company
uh you can see there we have dr alfred
tauber he comes with a from a from a
medical background with expertise in
oncology um
immunology about chemistry of
information one of this project is the
establishment of the
the taobao bioinformatics research
center which has been the core
of what is is being done at times today
we also have doctor johnny broski is the
director of the taoba bioinformatics
research center and is an expert in
bioinformatics and biostatistics he has
numerous publications on bioinformatics
and other
and and over the course of his career he
has developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis yeah these have
been widely used in basic and
translational research in
biotechnology
pharmaceutical
rnd research and development
[Music]
agriculture biomedical research tensor
and so what we will discuss today is
also a result of the hard walks the hard
work of some of the people mentioned
here on the left you can find julia uh
bernard you can uh she's an expert in
bioinformatics
in bioinformatics and just help prepare
many of the materials we will use uh we
also have av
he is a computer scientist and
and leads the development of the tebow
info platform we will also be introduced
to that we haven't been introduced that
we also have
mohit mozilla he's the head of the
disney development global we have joshua
mckendall we it
maintains the educational web portal uh
we will leveraging that we also have
senator ray uh
i guess some of us get get mails from
her she's a global community manager
so
this is like an introduction about it by
bio
the pine biotech
incorporated
usa
i believe you follow to this point you
follow to this point just go to the chat
and write one just write one so over the
course
of the past years
uh over the past several years we see
how that prime biotech team has been
collaborating with numbers of academic
institutions around the world
that have participated in
content
evaluation curriculum review and project
design now omixological research based
training as a result of
such close collaboration as a result the
omixology program has been thoroughly
evaluated and
unknown to lead
to excellent outcome importantly
uh programs are designed to support
students with minimal
uh not just student faculties uh with
minimal environments background
including biology
medical
uh people within about medical majors
and
and so on as well as faculty members i
observed that uh menopausal and body are
mostly faculty members that are
interested in catching on with the trend
the omics era
uh trend in bioinformatics so
and uh it also
extends faculties that are that are
interested in data science about medical
researches and so far
on this note
i would love to bring to us
uh
what
and why we a year
so
moving on into the specifics of this
information session on research
fellowship today our aim is to provide
all of the detailed information
to perspective participant in our
research fellowship
towards helping participants join our
bioinformatics community
with the goal of leveraging on
on the available training
uh resources and the tools for the
journey
into bioinformatics and
big data science analysis to improve
their research skills and also to be
able
to play an important role in the omics
science era
in this session
uh we will be having
um
you intent
or
you join the research fellowship program
where the participant will have to learn
to identify a research topic of interest
yeah to perform literature review to
refine it
in the context of what is i mean is
acceptable in bioinformatics and to find
a data set from the public repositories
or to work on their own raw data
for their home project so you also learn
about translating your ideas or
questions into
an analysis plan that you can execute as
well as learn about project
presentations writing and final
submissions
that
so that you can be prepared to share
the result
with a greater scientific
community
so
uh before i call on uh
on the program director to speak with us
i would love to introduce us to our
bioinformatics trading tools and
resources platform
and this is very about
the pine biotech
uh what about with the omixlogic program
for africans come in with a vision of
empowering
practitioners and students medical
scientists such as
requisite knowledge and q said in big
data science and bioinformatics so has
to be able to adequately play
i know to take a place in the or mix
in this era
at this point allowing me to have
particular focus on
the research fellowship mr adekunle i
hope you are there can you take over
mr ade colleen are you there
hello thank you can you hear me
okay thank you good afternoon everyone
so please permit me to share my screen
now yes thanks very much
okay
a minute
can you see my screen
yes
yes you can see your screen
oh sorry just a minute
all right
thank you very much
hello
hello
yes please i hope i'm audible now yes
yes
yes we can see your screen
ice cream thanks so much good afternoon
everyone
thank you mister and your follower for
the introduction
yes um it's my pleasure to talk to you
more about the research fellowship
training program this afternoon uh my
name is adequate i'm a faculty with leed
city university in nigeria and also a
mentor with fine biotic
i have my background
i can't hear you again
i think it's the network please it's
going to
sorry about that
so i was introducing myself my name is
adi claire dilloy i'm a faculty
university here in nigeria and i mentor
with spain biotech and i have my
background in medical laboratory
sciences
currently lecture body medical
scientists nurses are nursing and
radiography professionals here in my
university um however my area of course
is molecular biology and genomics and
presently i'm exploring the
opportunities that
is in bioinformatics and big data
science with research interest in
transcriptomic efficiencies and
precision oncology
besides this i'm also a
i'm researcher a head premiere and a
mentor facilitator and so i start
currently as the program director for
miss logic um africa with pioneer tech
usa okay so today um
moving on i'd like to remind us
of the goals we are running with in umix
logic programs globally
i want to believe some of us on this
webinar this afternoon we've
participated in some of our programs in
time past and in case you have not i
mean some of our basic programs in case
you have not i believe you will equally
you know get to learn from what we'll be
presenting this afternoon so first
our goal is to provide training in
bioinformatics enabling independent
research that is guided by mentors and
peer examples and
of course we
also develop we are working to develop a
growing community with shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation of citizen science and in
addition to that
um is enabling students scientists or
clinicians and faculty as well as
lecturers researchers okay of upper
grass to develop new independent
research that you know by using latest
technology in life and data and sciences
all right uh but yes let's quickly i
mean just brush i mean look at what
bioinformatics is all about
bioinformatics can be said to be the
intersection of informatics or the signs
of processing data for storage retriever
uh you know storage and retrieval as
well as you know the biology of the
study
of law of living organisms all right
yeah biology is about the story of
living out music so and then informatics
informatics it's in itself it's a
science of processing data you know for
storage and retriever okay it's an
information science what biology is say
is study of living organisms so
bioinformatics is a you know is is the
marriage of these two disciplines okay
into one and so performance can be said
to be
its subdiscipline of biology or and
computer science that is concerned with
acquisition storage analysis and
determination of biological data so that
tells us that
beats i mean your background might be in
the biologists i want to say biology of
course be it agriculture i mean i mean
we want the life sciences all of them
has their business in biology medical
science has their business in biology
okay
agricultural slt laboratory technology
all of them medical laboratory science
has their business and biology so we are
referring to all of these you know when
we refer to biology and of course um for
informatics essentially we are looking
at those coming from iet and information
technology computer science you know
feed so all of these persons can come
you know have a convergence and have a
role to play when it comes to
bioinformatics so um it shouldn't
surprise you when you come across um
individuals who probably in their first
degree or previous um discipline they
are a biochemist or a medical doctor
agriculturalists and today they are
experts in bioinformatics and equally of
course you might see people whose first
degree is totally in
communication science i mean computer
sciences and the rest and today the
bioinformatics working with
[Music]
persons development drug development and
so many other things okay so
bioinformatics is that you know i mean
corners that brings these two
disciplines together and the fact is
that the influence of data associated
methodologies and data driven research
makes bioinformatics for life sciences
as prominent as even the emergence of
computers or technology for the tech
industry of course we know what and that
the role of that in the in the modern
world all right and one key thing also
that you know um
has brought today at the importance of
bioinformatics and the technology about
technology generally is the present
community now
okay um you know it has not only come to
test the scientific knowledge that we
have you know acquired or garnered over
the years okay and the advancement also
the various you know technological
development of the past decades no but
it does also come to show how important
these scientific breakthroughs you know
such as this next generation sequencing
and other molecular biology technologies
have become in helping us to cope with
the present pandemic that threatens the
very cover human existence and i think a
very uh you know fact that left that
lead
you know length credence to these is the
speed at which in vasin was developed
within months within months
you know thanks to some of these
technologies and the road bioinformatics
played in that particular
you know
discovery and advancement
all right so the fact um today is the
fact that biology is rapidly acquiring
the character of inductor science
right you know billions of data points
on genes proteins and other molecules
are compiled you know on a daily basis
in large price and systematically become
strategy okay so analyzing this data
would definitely lead to more knowledge
and understanding about living organisms
including human head about technology
crops and livestocks just to mention you
know a few
okay now looking at next generation
sequences you know the development of
the nigerian sequencing platforms that
is the ngs
address the speed the cost and
throughputs
i mean the gaps has
previously existed when it comes to
speed cost and throughputs right so the
engines platforms has come to address
this and so the the clinical
representing us amino has been able to
play a significant role as this
technology has paved the way for a new
era in genomics and its application
across various feats
all right
and so um the immense amount of complex
detail that are generated by next
generation supremacy instrumentation has
however mean a challenge to laboratories
and research institutional scientists
you know across the globe why because
there's a need for concomitant
investment as well as advances in
informatics and laboratory systems that
is able to handle this data otherwise
these data have just been churned out
you know some are you know published and
then they remain there in silos in our
storage and archival files without any
translational means of making them
useful for mankind so the combination of
new knowledge regarding the molecular
business of disease and in nova
technologies um we know that we
are here talking about such as the ngs
we facilitate for that groups in this in
this area and so the next important
component that need equal if not much
more attention now these kid
professionals key scientists like you
and i that are able to respond
adequately to these opportunities and
challenges of making you know critical
meaning out of these data that are being
generated from our laboratories all
right and this is because the
interpretation of process data is also a
challenge
requiring multiple steps and informatics
tools you know used in turn them to
generate a final result from the raw
data that was initially you know
sequenced from a sequencer so
collectively these twos are called the
bioinformatics pipeline and if critical
part of sample analysis and generation
of or of results okay and for us as we
enter into the era of um science all
right we talked today about who makes
their genomics transcriptomics
metabolomics you know chemothermatics
and all of that as we enter into this
missions era in which incorporation of
genomic information becomes a rooting
part of you know researches and medical
care and scientific you know activities
all professionals all scientists
especially biomedical scientists and
physicians we need a basic education in
bioinformatics all right you know in
addition to the molecular abuse of
disease or
you know the the basic sciences you know
behind these diagnosis treatment disease
monitoring and so so many other you know
scientific endeavors that we already
process all right um because genomic
science and molecular parameters are
very relevant in many others today you
know fits like agriculture even defense
pharmaceutical industries animal
husbandry veterinary medicine microbial
sciences just to mention a few so every
researcher and scientist need to acquire
these regular skills
that is needed in these in this era in
order to remain relevant
okay and that is the rationale behind
our mission and goals with women's logic
programs so because bioinformatics is
very broad in terms of you know it is a
very pro term that combines data
business agory teams you know data and
green and so many other tools and
concepts like that and with the advanced
personal computing and cloud solutions
that is available today it is obvious
that the feed will continue to even
develop you know in engineering as well
as biological knowledge accommodation
and so user-friendly tools for only
complex um data without demanding the
engineering skills or the coding skills
is very very important and this is where
the omis logic platform actually comes
in and that is where we bring the code
and no code by informatics together
because actually when you talk about
bioinformatics there's the programming
language the coding aspect that is
expected but of course many of us might
not even know i mean i mean i for one
think my
basic or very crude knowledge of
programming language was html which i
cannot even
proudly say i can work on today okay and
many of us we don't even i mean that's
not my feed i'm not a computer scientist
however with bioinformatics i've come to
um learn how to build you know interact
with both the code the coding part as
well as the no code but no coding part
of bioinformatics as a researcher to
make a meaning out of you know data that
are being generated in a laboratory so
hence the whole essence of this webinar
this information section this afternoon
is to present to everyone what they need
to get started in bioinformatics
especially as it concerns the research
fellowship program we are here talking
about
all right so the research fellowship
proper let me talk about that we have a
research fellowship in computational
biology
also if you visit our platform you also
get to see the research fellowship fall
2021 i mean those are the two different
research fellowships you can sign on to
as we speak even um on prime biotech
umass logic platform so the research
fellowship program has been designed to
help young researchers and students meet
undergraduate or postgraduates to take
advantage of the bioinformatic resources
for analysis of complex
high throughput life sciences data and
become fast in bioinformatics all right
this program offers
participants and you know it offers
everyone to opportunity to participate
in real and coordinate bioinformatics
research and to be a part of a renowned
bioinformatics and community
the fellowship program will offer a
combination of both online resources as
well as mentor guidance to prepare you
and help you complete a bioinformatics
project so one goal one
key outcome of participating as a
research fellow in our research
fellowship is producing a project which
of course together with your mentors on
the program you can go ahead to publish
them in a reputable journal
across the globe as has been done by
past alumni of the same program so the
fellowship requires each student to pay
for the training each person to pay for
the training the mentorship and the big
data analytics um you know assets
through rt buying full server so if you
ask me essentially three things that any
um i mean
i want the training
training the other thing is mentorship i
mean guidance on between you're gonna do
it yourself but then the guidance all
right and of course you needed the the
tiba info server all right let me see
this one of the key challenge to buy
from us generally is the infrastructure
demand
okay you can imagine you're able to come
across maybe you're interested in
running
you know searching on the
the various data repositories to look at
what data set is available that talks
about the contents who's the
relationship between
saskatchewan the consecutive agent for
kuvy 19 and maybe diabetics and then you
come across a data set that is publicly
uh published in direct procedure that
runs into maybe one terabyte that is
about 1 000 gigabytes all right so how
do you get to download this is it with
your data to download onto your system i
mean these are our challenges and we
really have um super computers so i mean
when i even say supercomputers we really
have that even in this part of the world
even mac mark system which is known to
be quite rugged and a bit
you know solid to undo some of these
things many of us cannot afford this
many of us cannot access this right
right and i think i have one of our
great ambassadors who was trying to walk
through a similar challenge i hope he's
on this um this meeting i can bear
witness to this you have to crash two
systems two system concurrently while
trying to download the data and use
available softwares to run them so what
that brings us to is the fact of us
using cloud-based servers
super computers virtual machines to run
these services and of course many of us
might not be able to set this up or even
pay for it all right and so this is one
of the other things we are actually
paying for in big data analytics server
um by t buying through which participant
on the research fellowship will have
access to use to run their program
um so the platform is a cloud-based
analytical server that is used by
research laboratories and independent
scientists all around the globe and i'm
proud to let you know that it is
artificial intelligence guided meaning
meaning it is safe in treaty all right
and that is where the non-coding part of
learning bioinformatics and getting good
graphs of it actually
comes in all right so the first thing um
i'd like to establish is what you miss
logic portal we have our sponsors to get
from
the first is learning about the mix
generally and the logic behind the
analysis of large and complex commits
data some of the courses we have access
to on the platform for those of our
participants who have not done this
before because like i said we have
organized series of basic introductory
programs which some of us have
participated and had access to taking
these courses and so we are aware of it
already however whether you've taken it
before you want to retake it of course
being part of this program you can
refresh and i mean refresh your
yourselves by taking these courses or if
you have not taken this program before
equally you can as well i mean maintain
their instinctualness courses which is
at your pace um to take all right so um
we also practice various information
guided tutorials and wrong analysis
right you know in our browser so these
are some of the various courses we have
on the platform equally participants
will be able to gain an advantage and
measure their progress using our you
know point system okay you can see here
on the slide here every of the sessions
you are going through those courses
those asynchronous courses you get to
complete when you click complete you any
points and all of that so you are is a
point b system you do nothing you're not
gonna you're not gonna end any point or
you get doing involved engaging those
activities you can measure your progress
as you move on and then you can get to
complete lessons on effective use of
popular packages of analysis
visualization and annotation of complex
biological data such as the sequence
data we are here and talking about and
then you get to become proficient also
at coding all right you can learn to
code because some of you know we have
courses on the platform that introduces
perspective you know programming
essential programming languages that are
relevant to bioinformatics such as the
arrow programming as well as python
programming right python is the roots i
mean the basis of most of the machine
learning you'll be hearing about machine
learning uh martial television a lot of
that python is is one of the programming
language that's at the root of this and
so you can get to understand some of the
algorithms and approaches to biological
data analysis here on the platform the
last slide that comes up here um is you
know a screenshot from our server where
you get to see some of these videos and
algorithms each of these buttons here
are various algorithms with scientific
published research you know publications
packing them up
martika modes on which at a click of
reporting you can apply to your own data
and then get the same results as a
computer scientist or
bioinformaticians would have
okay and so it is good that we also get
to understand better by exploring
created data sets is one of the things
participants of your situation you know
go on to benefit you can understand data
and what's the meaning i mean the
scientific process that has been applied
to them by previous you know researchers
you know by simply you know um you know
following this community related data
sets all right and then you can also
gain access to various project examples
to provide insights and guide in your
own personal research project using
bioinformatics tools okay some of it
have been listed here
on the screen all right you can learn
also from experienced mentors of course
that are available on the program you
know to you know by joining the program
and then get the needed guidance that is
needed for you to complete your own
project so here of course the first
project there we have this liquid
analysis of affected biological pathways
in multiple sclerosis this was published
by one of the past participants it is a
project simply going through it looking
at what they did how they explained what
they did i mean
on their data set and all of that you
begin to get insight into this and what
you could do in your own domain um the
area of expertise the next one is the
invasion of biomarkers for
prostate cancer using bioinformatics of
course then bioinformatics approach to
analyze variants in retinol um you know
where in retinol retinitis pigmentosa
all right ropd all right so and then on
and on like that we also have random
forest classification of bacterial sim
classifier for patch recent
classification this is another project
and on and on like that someone also
worked on transcriptomic analysis of cd4
t cells for hiv genes so these are
several things that is possible you know
wheat and during this program and it
will interest you to know that most of
these projects were done
you know carried out on publicly
available data sets that is data
sequences that people have you know
conducted as their own research are
published and then you see the same
research get access to their metadata
information about the samples and then
apply it to a different hypothesis
scientific study and you come up with
different results that is equally
publishable all right so this is what is
possible with this research fellowship
and this is where i find very
interesting and helpful actually about
it and cloud-based um you know ai guided
server for parts funds to utilize in
their learning journey because here on
this slide is a screenshot from project
pipelines that was run using the cloud
bc server by
okay and it is an ai guided platform
like i said okay when you click the
start button i mean the next possible
buttons are highlighted for you to click
and of course depending on what you want
to do which you have
gained the knowledge about from the
asynchronous courses you get to click
those buttons and then the next you are
guided through essentially that is what
this program offers and i like to add
that um during the course of this
program all of our online training will
be leveraging on both cloud-based
technology like the t-bus info server i
mentioned lr as well as you know the
detailed training resources that is
available on our bioinformatics training
page the len.logie.com
which i hope i will be introducing to
ross even before the end of this session
today
okay so um
learning bioinformatics eases challenge
we must accept that of course it is not
challenging i don't think you and i
should be here but we want to overcome
this challenge so there are many
technical hobbies to overcome but also
many issues regarding the complexity of
the data that represents biological
medical technological questions that is
being studied i want to tell you it's an
exciting journey if you've been part of
even our business programs beforehand
lay your hands on some of the demo
details to run analysis on them you will
agree with me it's an exciting journey
but of course like i said it is
challenging equality and that is why
mixed logic is a place where you can
learn about the logic behind
bioinformatics to leverage big data
analyze it effectively following a clean
logic and make your own analysis
reproducible of course and then we also
recommend your use of a tip buy info
platform so essentially the vision is to
make bioinformatics accessible and
useful without unnecessary complications
that include non-experts and make
conventional tasks extremely burdensome
would see maybe you know especially when
we join the program you get to meet all
crops of
you know participants we have um
you know researchers we have um you know
technicians we have undergraduates only
the program of course it's not there's
no limitation there's no criteria for
you coming in all you need is a basic
understanding of biology and maybe
ability to use your system or your
smartphone definitely you can you can do
well on the program we have in fact
we've seen projects on our platform
completed by high school students high
school i mean secondary school in our
own balance here all right they've gone
ahead learn these programs and applying
what they've learned the algorithms and
all of that it can apply to
availabilities and make money out of it
okay so it is something we can um do so
the vision is to make it accessible to
everyone and so talking specifically now
regarding the research fellowship
program
all right the research
fellowship program is is designed to
provide theoretical and practical
training for those that are interested
in next generation sequencing data
which is becoming widely accessible and
variety of topics okay and in the
program you will learn about this type
of data how to identify a research topic
how to perform literature review to
refine it because of course if i'm going
to pick a data set that has been
published by
um you know by some maybe a researcher
in china or some researcher in u.s or
just anywhere across the group because i
will have you need to understand what
they did their research and of course
that gives me a lot of background
understanding into the metadata of that
particular sample and that was worked
upon and i can know how to understand
and use that better even for my own
scientific studies so there's a need for
literature review and study and of
course also because we want to also
perhaps i want to work on maybe
you know
[Music]
hepatitis b you know
research now i guess they need for me to
understand that you mean you know of
knowledge and what has been done even
outside of even bioinformatics and how i
want to apply that to it so there's a
need for
that aspect and there's need for us to
prepare our samples process how to
process and prepare um you know our data
set for analysis as well as utilize data
science keys to mine and visualize this
large dataset and present
our research to peers and experts for
feedback so that's one also one other
key thing you know you get to learn on
the program um you know the program runs
everywhere is the research values
research values you know are expected to
join in the research fellows
associations of course it is uniquely
available the link is available uniquely
available to them and you see
participants depending on your i mean
your time your your your your
position on the program okay maybe for
example those who have joined for the
past three months or five months and
actually getting towards the end of
their project okay you see them
presenting their project and of course
in that session you learn for what they
have done you're going to pick insight
onto what you should do what you can
also apply in your own study fully sims
and strategies okay an equality
awareness program also serves to present
feedbacks on what you've learned
or your challenges on your own project
as the project is ongoing okay so all of
these skills presentation skills talking
like an expert with bioinformatics
terminologies and concepts are what you
are going to learn on the program
so at this point um of course some of
the trainers mentors and facilities on
the program includes uh
chief executive officer of pemba tech
himself he's an industry expert
consultant and also a trainer we have uh
dr abraham um who is in fact in charge
of the research fellowship program he's
an omis logic trainer and we
and he's um he's a bioinformatician and
computing computational biologist we
also have mohibs
among other you know international
mentors as well of course locally here
in nigeria so we have a team of experts
and faculties who will be supporting us
in terms of you know facilitating some
of the sessions for us and also
supporting all of um materials
part of the program during the course of
these training and i'd like to mention
that actually the program is a
certificate program meaning traditional
aspects of the program going to nc bit
of completion in many of the insecure
nurse courses because what happens is as
you join the program um you have access
to the platform and you're able to take
relevant in-synchronous courses as many
as you want or relevant to your
specialization tracks okay take for
example you have like 10 different
synchronous concepts right from the
basics introductory
introduction to bioinformatics vitamin
to rest transcriptomics or including
projects that has been done right from
the beginning how those projects were
done okay and the sample data said you
could even visit those example this
asset i've had the demo pipeline and see
how it was done okay so all of this you
get access to it and on each of those
courses you end in certain kids so if
you complete genomics introduction to
genomics when you set it for that if you
complete transcriptomics you any
certificate for that so you can acquire
a number of these safeties and at the
end also you can end the certificate for
the program like what we have here um
research fellowship um you know for 2021
programs so viral program are you you
get to enter and participants based on
the activity on the platform can
actually go on to end ten thousand
points and more
at which point you you you end the
circuit of excellence beyond disability
completion special recognition
for our community all right so the
fellowship requires each password to be
called like i mentioned earlier
which covers training mentorship and
access to the big data analytics server
platform you will be using to analyze
relevant details that said that you have
found on
various publicly available
representations okay um here is a
typical registration cost for a three
month program so i'm sure some of us
might be heating at this point yes
and
it is something of course that um is
result oriented it's a cost that is
going to deliver on needs purpose
so there are three level of
participation
membership for training program like you
see there we have beginner intermediate
and advanced however of course the basic
membership the beginner membership will
provide persons access to all of these
um all of the courses and the resources
available in the training however what
intermediate provides over and above the
beginner is an access to a one-on-one
mentorship um you know and during the
program of course meaning not just the
general mentor more like having just one
supervisor uh supervisor attached to you
so to say that is
what it means but like i said all
beginners all participants are busy get
to enjoy mentorship during the program
as a matter of fact right and for the
advanced the reason why it is 550
dollars beyond you know the for the
others is that the type of license you
get with that is what we call research
lines research license on our tbr input
platform that is that server platform
you use to analyze data the advantage of
that is you can actually bring your own
sequence data
meaning not data that you downloaded
from repositories now you access through
repositories your own sequence data you
can work on that so if you are on the
beginner program and maybe you are
thinking of you know actually bringing
the data generated in your own
laboratory please what you should go for
is the restart um you know
is the advanced packet which allows you
to bring bits you want to bring
because the the basically the
intimidating those ones comes with
education analysis which allow you to
import data directly some of them you
might just need to point the url of that
data through ftp links from maybe ncbi
or from assembly straight to the server
and then the rest is done okay but for
this where you needed to upload the data
maybe it's 500 you really realize 250
gig i'm sure you know this is going to
be resource demanded and all of that and
for some other um necessary
steps in the process there is a need for
you to obtain a research line so i think
that
um tests us that advance would be more
relevant for us
in direct speed however i have a good
news for us i mean for us in africa
which is the reason why we are
conducting this um you know information
section there's a special registration
fee for us okay
so what does that mean for beginner and
you could see there is a per month there
all right so one of the first things
this specialization or participation or
window that is provided for omis logic
africa participant that is people from
our environment here because we have
whom is logic india omits logic u.s
logic sri lanka and
across the globe like that so homosexual
africa which we are here i mean talking
about here um headquarter here in
nigeria from now yes for now um so we
have the special discounted cost at per
month basis so meaning um
so if you are coming in for a
three-month internship or research
fellowship we have two frameworks two
timelines either three months or six
months
so you are coming in for three months
meaning
that is 150 dollars you get to pay 150
dollar better at once depending on the
link you want or your request or even
you could pay it at monthly okay monthly
subscription meaning 50 dollar month one
50 months to fifty dollar monthly so you
get to enjoy that same thing rather than
a three hundred dollar payment at least
required just like the slide i showed
previously
you get to enjoy a 50
scholarship or discount that makes you
pay 15 dollars monthly
and like i said you can pay that 50 50 i
mean the whole total fee of 150 but we
want to make things accessible and much
more convenient for our people and that
is why you can actually pay 50 monthly
however it's a suspicious movie meaning
if today's 27 months if i go ahead and
make my payment today by 27th of next
month
50 dollars equivalent your narrative
will be automatically deducted by 27 of
the full amount it gets detected again
okay and so that's for the three months
but if your desires for system which i
would like to clarify also why you know
why
okay of course that goes to 350 dollar
in six months however the payment will
be taken not in six months it will be
taken in three months it's only three
months installment payment that is
allowed for us by our principals with
pine bounty okay but of course it still
makes things quite easier and you know
you have a long haul to actually go
through the program and so for three
months programs of course maybe if you
have proud understanding of
bioinformatics or you've gone through
some of our basic program and you're
actually really set to hit the ground on
your program and the projects are
complete you walk within three more then
yes you can go for the three-month
program however if you want to really go
in for a long haul ensure you get the
very best of the program maybe you don't
have good background before now and then
also importantly because you are
targeting publishing a paper out of this
exercise then maybe the six months will
be recommended and so on then of course
you can come into this program
of course similar to what i explained
later on intermediates simply provide
you a level of one-on-one mentorship
ahead of just the general one and also
the advanced gives you access to using
your own data set all right however the
basic program the beginner assets gives
you everything i mean it gives up but
spent almost the same thing other than
those few things which um you know
depending on your desire you might want
to get and so if this small internship
will come to 300 dollars for a beginner
um 450 dollar for an intermediate 594
dollars for advanced okay
um whereas for
um three more it will be 150
205
but of course like i said the advantage
is you can pay
these money instrumentally making it
much more easier and
so
uh moving on
i like to also request at this point um
for those of us who are possibly
not part of any of our previous programs
or you know to go to our lender commis
logic platform which is the gateway to
our activities to register on that
platform okay let's start by signing up
it is free to sign up to this
educational quota and it will help you
get started on your bioinformatics
journey okay registration of course
provides you access to a number of three
courses we have a number of frequencies
and i intend showing them to ross here
this afternoon um especially for those
of us who want to get on either before
you come on board or even right now as
you are coming on board you can
latch on some of those
on those courses and start doing their
own finding actually interesting
um
so i encourage you to register on the
platform and once you register on the
platform the first thing i recommend is
to you know immediately you log in you
get to see your name or your email
address to click on that email address
or your name it brings you to a page
like this this is your own personal
profile all right this is your personal
profile it is strongly recommended that
you go on to complete your personal
profile but adding you know once again
when you scroll down you need to when
you are live on the page you see edit
profile okay when you click on that or
profile once you click on that you can
get to add your profile picture your
avatar picture complete your naming full
some people may be initially well
registered just put a nickname or just a
single name because whatever is here is
what gets displayed on your certificate
automatically and we also encourage you
to go ahead to add all your
you know linkedin
facebook instagram especially your
research id or kid ib
link and your twitter link of course
this is to help this community get to
know you especially when people are
looking for people to work with i mean
collaborate with
in terms of research this will be very
relevant and of course um here i have a
slide of on this slide someone who has
done this um this is short bar about
this person the naming food
except for facebook i mean
almost all the um other personal ids
were added and of course the last
activities and activity laws based on
the courses especially taking on our
platform can be readily seen here
all right and so
um i would like to recommend that we
also visit the program page the link
will be posted in the chat
for us okay the program page for the
research fellowship we have the program
page for the computational biology
internship program and equally like i
said we have research fellowship for
2021 which is
starting you know now i think the
research relationship actually starts
today
of course it's a run the year program
you can join at any point in time but of
course we have
more lucky patches
all right and so the next patch actually
commences today august 17th sorry
september 27th and it's running through
to december um
is the 28th or thereabout
is december okay so you can join you can
join in you can join in november you can
join in december of course your own
system starts and when we have another
batch we are actually you know
publishing requesting applications for
of course they come and they join you
and you'll be processed then they'll
probably be doing your presentations
when they are just starting and all of
that so it's a recursive um program but
we recommend that you consider journey
right off because nobody knows what the
rates and costs and all of them may
become and so um would be sharing the
best payment link for those of us i mean
coming in and joining from africa of
course to be able to enjoy some of those
benefits there will be a need to share
the stock payment link which is
currently not available just reach out
to us on our whatsapp page and then or
via our email africa find about or even
file you can drop your email or i mean
get to contact us and we'll definitely
respond to you we already set up your
whatsapp page and i think we also
provide you whatsapp so that you are not
already on that page you can kindly join
and you know get to learn more and hear
all that is necessary for you to
be a part of this program and make the
best of it all right so i mentioned
earlier on that there are some frame to
draw recourses i'd like to introduce you
guys so um where are you taking this
before
or some of the because some perspective
this program actually have gone through
some of our basic programs and i think
at this point let me mention we run a
number of basic programs introductory
programs around the yeah in fact there
is one that is currently going on we
just finished section two it's a seven
week section uh program meaning seven
sections and we're just um through in
section two last victories if you still
want to join that they're very much
welcome because it will provide you a
lot of groundwork of physics that is for
those who have not gone through any of
our programs before usually recommend
that if there are people who when they
throw in the applications for research
solutions and the international
review committee once they are going
through the
attempts tonight because
they don't want to the research is more
like an advanced level of this program
right which is why i recommend if you
are coming in for three months you
should have had maybe you have gone
through past programs and you have some
basic knowledge in this in this field
but if you are coming for six months
equally at times we even still recommend
why not join in an introductory program
which usually is at a lesser cost it
gets you familiar with our platform it's
so familiar with concepts and a lot of
things happening in the field of next
generation sequencing big data analysis
error coding python coding impact and
all of that okay so like i said i will
release the link to this program this
particular course is available because
all the lessons in these courses we have
playlists they are totally free meaning
you don't have any payment or joining
any program you can access this
course so the link will be provided now
is
this an introductory course that covers
topics of big data bioinformatics and
its uses in basic research healthcare
and biotech and pharmaceutical
industries so in many ways advances in
this display have helped make major
discoveries in the recent years and this
is what this program will be intro and
this course will be introducing youtube
all right another um course on our
program of course 2 which is what i
reconvened um incidentally like i said
if you have taken this course before
maybe joining our programs before now i
recommend university before now this
course used to have like four or five
lessons currently it has ten lenses
meaning your equal that means
improving on our courses by the day all
right i think you provide the
opportunity to go through that into
interest to know that all of the ten
lenses in these ten lessons in this
course are totally free okay and so um
you know the concept behind this is that
every living says house is no hard drive
which is you know they are stored in
bites
and uh you know
bites of information in our system and
so we get to understand that and they
grow on to um see um the business of dna
coding and all those other biomedical
data
you know
resources and terminologies
the third course i would like to also
introduce to ross now this is called
course nine this is particularly
important for us who are interested in
research finishing it is called
designing a bioinformatics research
project i'm sure that would be very
interesting and you know course
to take it has just three lessons and i
think it's just the lesson one that is
um free for now i think lesson two and
three should be premier but i
i'm not too sure but there is a plan to
make it totally free so that might have
been activated already so i would say
encourage you go ahead and join you
might be able to just um you know take
all of the courses the premium code
lessons rather the premium lessons are
those that are carrying stars or click
on it and
you know take all of your courses so in
the course you will learn how to
identify a research topic how to perform
literature review to refine it and also
find data set for your project in a
liberal
repository so
all of these are possible through
these
three courses i've introduced to ross i
think the links has been shared on the
platform so um
why i wait um
our questions at this point to make it
interactive and answer me outstanding
things i might have not touched during
this presentation we would like to also
um
talk about i mean introduce some short
videos okay that will further go ahead
to elucidate i mean i mean clarify a
number of things regarding the program
okay
a video short video research fellowship
that was released just last week
by our ceo that is um
and equally we have a video about the
research experience of one of the past
alumni who actually came in for three
months and before they
wasn't in fact exposed to informatics
but it was interesting to see what he
has been able to achieve all right in
fact he's really doing a lot of um you
know work in aggro uh i'm sorry astro
biology uh umix
in recent times so
that video will be an interesting one to
the link will be available in the chat
i'd like someone to please help me post
it um mr victor or i in fact please can
hear me post
those links all right and then we also
have another video by um someone else um
who actually also is an alumni
of of the program those two videos were
shared just for us to have a
perspective
you know of what lies ahead in the
program and equally
the video on homology research
fellowship is equally added so making
about four videos we'll be sharing with
you so um on that note i want to welcome
our questions now um those that as we
posted in the chat or those that we
might want to ask thank you very much
for your audience so questions
questions about the program mr young
follower do we have questions already in
our chat box
um i'm going to the chat now
and
i'm trying to go around to see
the questions we have
um
there is a question on our
um
what's hap group um
let me just
read it out
yeah so uh
i think you've answered most of the
questions yeah one of the questions here
was
how long will it take
so
you you helped you helped to clarify
that
um
they
we have two categories
uh
of duration we have the three months and
we have the sixth month
so um so that's uh one one of the
questions
yeah then
the other one was asking about
how much will it take and if there is
any any scholarship
can you answer that
okay yes so um like i said
uh we
were able to discuss with um
biotech and
i mean the management to have a reason
to consider a special discount
for africans before now of course we
have people from africa
our research fellowship before now and
what usually is done
you know they have to fill an
application for scholarship
which will be reviewed and in the
application you get to submit two
referees who can be contacted and all of
that and equally participate in your
learning journey with the program and
all of that and at the end but when i
offered 50
or 30
scholarship all right um
i think the highest i've seen was a 70
percent scholarship meaning the person
gets to pay 30 percent of that cost all
right but of course i'm sure you know
these will be first few among many who
might probably be asking for this same
scholarship but of course at this point
moving forward we've been able to also
you know
negotiate and agree off
as i just presented a 50
scholarship for everybody
because of course the program is now
offered at 50 discounted cost for
africans and people from you know um low
income communities low income and
countries all right so that is already
in existence and this same program in
the same research fellowship you get to
meet people who will be paying as much
as
550 dollars 594 dollars or i mean what i
view depending on the length
of time they are coming in for the
program i'm sure the program that comes
from 550 dollars should be about 900 or
thereabouts if it's going for six months
or you know so to say the advanced level
so
it is heavily discounted already help
you eat
upbeat if there is a need for to still
put in for scholarship well you may just
um you know apply that but
the the research scholarship is actually
intended for people who are already a
fellow on the program
who possibly after they are through
their projects they've completed the
project and all of that they need
further assets maybe for them maybe you
did it three months into
or be able to publish that research
because the process will still be
ongoing
what have you for subsequent
such participants who have a computer
program whose project is possibly listed
on the blend dots domestic platform you
already qualify for some level of
scholarship either food or fashion
because
in a way your project is contributing
also to that platform now by being
published so if you have not published
you have not given to this community i
mean maybe
enjoying a more scholarship
might not be really feasible but the
board there is
the organization provides a lot of
recommendations linkages for even other
scholarships outside of comics logic
eventually you want to participate in a
phd program we research grants and all
of that just feel free to share with us
and then the necessary linkages we
provided where needed recommendations
provided so all of that goes on and on
while being part of the human logic
community i hope i believe it
yeah thank you very much for that for
that answer
and for the question another question
that i can see here
is to know if uh
if during in the course of the research
fellowship there will be a group work
yes thank you very much for that
question so usually merely you come on
board to the program
there are you know there are forms that
are made available where you feel
indicating your area of research
interests all of these and that's why i
recommend that third video i mentioned
the design research project a lot of
these has been also explained there with
videos resources and some other stuff
like that so it is required you feed the
form indicating what you want to work on
if at some point you need to feel you've
been it will be i mean you'll be shown
or taught
or i mean how especially if you have
purpose in some of our business programs
how to search relevant databases and
repositories for dataset that is useful
for your research you come back you
present it to the
mentors and the group they help you look
at it oh this is fine this is not good
enough why not this and in fact
attention you are searching for these um
you know data sets that is relevant to
your work you might not know where to
look so we'll be getting and supporting
all of these
okay so okay however
you can equally join other researchers
other researches that are going on by
other friends
and be a part of it there's room for
that meaning you are not coming up with
yours especially remember you are
learning by doing
doing a project so perhaps you don't
have an idea of yours first you just
want to join a project and be able to
complete that with such groups the
opportunities to come for
all parts
okay thank you very much so um
from that question uh that says that
idea project that needs groups to do
them i mean will you are we going to
group hall i mean group
i mean be grouped together
or
um can we also work independently i
think we've gotten there yes yes yes you
can work in the department and for the
grouping usually you just
once you join the session you see how
you have us to know what people are
working on in fact joining the session
is always inspiring you begin to see wow
how this person is thinking and that
begins to open your eyes to even what
you can do okay and so when you see you
hear all manner of topics and what
different pictures is ongoing if you're
interested in anyone you just indicate
to the program coordinators and then if
necessary and connections will be
established and you join the program he
did that particular project all right
especially if he's not
too far advanced already you join the
project and then you you go along with
that and that is why we said our profile
piece should be
you know
completed because by the time we
introduce you to an existing project now
please
suppose person is interested and then
those
on that project get to look up your
profile and then the soy blank i mean
they won't be encouraged to join okay
it's a research community
so that is why
you know you need to complete your
profile as well so it is very possible
just enjoy it okay
so the last question here from
from
a friend from sudan he says that
i need to participate in a project i
wanted to know
when will the the call
to join the research fellowship open
so
how soon can they start
all right so like i said you can start
right now in fact
like i said it's a recursive program you
can join and start
at the point you make your payment you
get all the necessary on boarding and
i mean details
to bring you into the program then you
are part of the program already and your
time starts access to the platform and
all of that will be activated for you
and then you begin to participate in the
program all right and so but like i
explained during the program you know
the the next cycle of call
for the program is on and it's starting
now september
even today today the research fellowship
for the research fellowship for 2012
starts today
okay i think the competition biology had
already started already all right so
you can join now and once you join
you'll be back we'll be compared to the
program right away however if you are
not joining right now it doesn't mean
you can't drive in november even in
december because the requested program
that you know registration is around the
year okay the dates you join you begin
to participate in the wednesday sessions
weekly sessions
the necessary forms you need to feel
regarding your interests and
messages follow up access to the
institutions courses starts for you the
day you make your payments when you join
so you can join you can start right off
especially now that is a new
cohort a new cycle is starting all right
of course there are people who have
started last month who started two
months ago they will always be together
in that same cohort but they are most
likely the ones that will be
presenting their
findings their report their results and
all of that or challenges they are
facing you know at the time you are
joining from which you will be learning
a lot of things and before you know it
while also taking those insecurities
courses filling your project ideal form
and all of that
starting your opinion which people who
will be joining november or december
will only be coming in so it is the
continuous circle so there's never a
right time to start down there
all right thank you very much for for
that so today is the right time
to join
um i think at this point
uh let me see if i have any other
question
so we don't have any other question oh
uh please if you have another question
can you
just do that quickly if not um
okay are they pages writing okay do you
have a question
okay other people said she has a
question
please
do share the question
i think she is still writing the
question
maybe she should permit herself quickly
okay would the recording to this session
be available
yes yes it will be available to be
shared
well
probably we'll be sharing it on our
whatsapp page so if you are part of that
page already
then you have it but if you are not
there please
i think the link for the um
whatsapp group is available kindly just
click and join that group and then
definitely you'll be able to access the
video
all right
i think we should end this session there
are no more questions
so i'm looking forward to your
engagement
the the program has started
the opportunity is open already
simply
reach out
we'll be posting the links to the
payments head out you want to pay once
whichever is convenient or you want to
pay instruments in instruments the links
will equally be made available so like
subscribe to it
mr your follower over to you please
thank you yeah so if you have any other
questions friends uh researchers
academia
um please do not hesitate to write us on
africa at pine dot
i want us to write that again i mean
write that down or take note of that
uh do feel free to
talk to us
on africa
at pine
dot bio so at this point
at this point i would love of course i
would love to take uh
i will also have a a a selfie moment
and um this self moment is a time when
when we get to to start our screen if
you are there please start your screen
we're about to have a selfie moment yes
if you're there please just start up
your screen about to to take a selfie
uh thank you very much for everyone that
um
that um
that has joined off so far okay so i
just turned it on there their screen oh
thank you very much i can see our
beautiful faces
okay so when i say
so when i say
um
[Music]
action just stay still and i will take
the selfie
okay so when i say action
just stay still and i will take this
selfie
are we ready
you're good
um mr tu mushay your camera is off again
uh we can't see you again okay
so
action
thank you very much uh you're going to
see the picture on our chat group thank
you very much everybody thank you very
much you've been it's been so
so lovely to
to be here with you
um thank you very much mr latif mr
deboey mr josephine
glory
mr ilami mr ebel mr liu
mr alfonk
mr tumishi
uh
let me tell you thank you very much uh
up to our madritos
yes uh this is
yeah so lovely to to be here with you
thank you very much you have a great day
everybody
thank you very much
yeah cheers